and of course there are so many
unanswered questions about the corona
virus and how it attacks the body blood
clots are turning up as a dangerous
problem in some patients and some
studies suggest around 30% of seriously
ill patients are developing these clots
and here in the US doctors reports
strokes even in patients under 50 CBS
News senior medical correspondent dr.
Tara Narula examines the troubling
symptom and what may be a promising
treatment and they have an appetite I
did course a little bit in April 33
year-old Warren L Vega thought he had a
common cold until his symptoms quickly
worsened I went to go wash my hands
right before turning on the water to a
little dizzy and then next thing I know
I was at the hospital Vega tested
positive for corona virus and x-rays
revealed another surprise blood clots in
his lungs Vega and many other
coronavirus patients some unusually
young are experiencing blood clots the
clots are impacting blood vessels large
and small arteries and veins all over
the body sometimes leading to
life-threatening conditions like
pulmonary embolism and stroke dr. Adam
Sucher studies blood clotting at the
University of Pennsylvania have there
ever been any other viruses that caused
this degree of clotting no the data that
I have seen so far suggests that the
risk of clotting with Kovach 19 is
greater than other infectious diseases
that we have observed a new
observational study from New York's
Mount Sinai Hospital suggests a
potential treatment doctors found that
treating hospitalized patients with
blood thinners to avoid clotting may
increase their chances of survival Mount
Sinai now preventatively treats most of
their kovat 19 patients with blood
thinners dr. valantine Foster is the
director of Mount Sinai Heart we found
eight anticoagulation decrease mortality
particularly in patients who were very
sick we are doing our second study of
6,000 patients and it appears we are
validating or happy with the first Reese
blood thinners help save Vegas life he's
out of Mount Sinai hospital and
recovering what message do you have to
other people and about Cova door about
surviving kovat if you do start feeling
sick please go get checked out right
away even you never know and doctor Rula
joins us now doctor good morning it's a
fascinating piece and really high stakes
for a lot of people do we know why blood
clots may be a complication of the virus
itself well Tony this is really one of
the biggest mysteries of kovat and
really one of the emerging and untold
stories we're learning a lot more every
day they're probably a combination of
factors contributing the first is that
we know that blood tends to clot when
it's stagnant when it's not moving
around so you can imagine an intubated
ventilated patient who's sedated or on a
paralytic is a setup for that there are
also issues with cytokine storm which
we've talked about are this immune
reaction which can cause the blood to
become hypercoagulable or very sticky
that can lead to clots and then one of
the most fascinating is that this seems
to also be a disease of the blood
vessels not just the lungs the same
receptor that the virus uses to get into
those lung cells is found on the lining
of all the blood vessels the ACE
receptor and so what we think is that
the virus may actually be damaging the
lining of the blood vessels and that can
lead to the clotting so really really
interesting and fascinating we're
learning a lot yeah very interesting we
saw the patient in your story was helped
by blood thinners and now there's
research into that as a treatment for
coronavirus how might that change the
typical treatment protocols for all
patients well that's why this story is
so important because we're learning that
this is such a big part of kovin 19 the
clotting that using blood thinners has
the potential to really impact so many
lives from some of these really
life-threatening complications like
stroke and pulmonary embolism we do need
the research though to really tell us
what type of blood thinners we have with
several different kinds on the market
what dose do we give it IV or in the
skin or orally and how long do we give
it and so as you heard a lot of
hospitals are already changing their
protocols where they're giving higher
doses than normal to kovat patients who
are in the ICU
and patients are getting discharged for
two weeks to a month on blood thinners
to again prevent the development of some
of these clots but we need those trials
to better inform us yeah oh of course
there are people who are are
convalescing at home who have the virus
so I'm curious for people in that
situation what are what are the signs
that a blood clot may be forming and
what should they do well certainly some
of the things that we worry about so DVT
or deep venous thrombosis if they notice
a leg that becomes warm or red or
swollen or painful that would be
concerning for a blood clot in the legs
pulmonary embolism where we form those
clots either in the lungs where they
travel from the deep veins of the legs
or the pelvis into the lungs chest pain
especially when you take a deep breath
or shortness of breath and then finally
stroke so if you have weakness or
numbness or lack of ability to move an
arm or a leg or even your face
difficulty with speech or vision any of
those signs should really prompt
somebody to get attention quickly all
right dr. Narula thank you very much